some of the best movie bad guys were
actually characters who started out good
and then became evil whether it be from
personal tragedy or coercion or maybe
they always had the potential to be bad
from the beginning here are some movie
heroes that epically turned into
villains
in the 2010 film megamind the titular
super villain grows bored after finally
defeating his arch enemy a superman
pastiche called metro man to get a taste
of their legendary battles once again
megamind secretly doses hapless
cameraman hal stewart with a concoction
that grants him super powers thus hal
becomes the new superhero titan which
she misspells at first hal behaves the
way any superhero should riding wrongs
and fighting megamind to protect the
city but soon hal's personal desires
start overtaking his duty towards his
city particularly his desire to make
news reporter roxanne richie love him in
the end megamind realizes he has
unwittingly created a new super villain
in titan and is forced to take on a more
heroic role to undo the damage wrought
by a crazed howl
at the time of the events of the lord of
the rings trilogy saruman the white had
already completed his descent into the
dark side and became a major villain but
later movies in the hobbit series that
were said in the past showed just how
noble and heroic saruman had once been
for centuries saruman leads the charge
in the battle against sarin but even
though he defeats sauron at one point
over time the lure of power proves too
much
eventually saruman's priority changes
from stopping sauron to expanding his
own influence over middle earth it is
this newly power hungry saruman who
comes into conflict with gandalf and his
allies during the events of the lord of
the rings we must join with him
we must join with saul
2012's twisted take on superhero origin
stories chronicle focused on andrew
detmer an awkward loner who gets abused
at home by his father and bullied in
school all while his mother is battling
cancer at his lowest point andrew his
cousin and friend come across a
meteorite-like object that grants them
superpowers at first andrew and his
friends use their powers to play pranks
fly around town and gain popularity at
their high school andrew's powers take
him in a darker direction he
accidentally kills one of his friends
and tries to use his powers to rob a
store so he can pay for his mother's
medication a series of misadventures
later andrew reaches his breaking point
and starts destroying everything around
him like a full-fledged super villain
until he's finally taken down by his
cousin
2015's the witch was anya taylor joy's
breakout role in the lead as thomason
the daughter of english settlers william
and catherine set in the 1630s the movie
follows william and his family as they
are expelled from a puritan colony for
william's controversial views the family
is forced to move to a desolate area
near the edge of the woods where they
must quickly try to store up enough food
for the long winter problems are
compounded by a coven of witches who
dwell in the woods and who have decided
to make william and his family their
latest victims thomason starts out a
good and virtuous character who tries
her best to get along with the
circumstances of her life but gradually
the bitterness of the family members
towards each other the paranoia
surrounding their religious dogma and
the machinations of the witches all
serve to overwhelm thomasin's conscience
in the end she has no choice but to join
the very same coven of witches that
destroyed her family just so she can
survive
a large part of the praise for the dark
knight comes in for the realism of the
movie which is what made harvey dent's
descend into becoming two-face all the
more heartbreaking in the beginning
harvey is the man that even batman
wishes he could be known as the white
knight of gotham harvey is the hot-shot
new district attorney who promises to be
uncompromising and tough on crime but
harvey's good intentions can't withstand
the onslaught of the diabolical joker
who's determined to prove that deep down
everyone else is just as twisted and
evil as he is thanks to a series of
tragedies engineered by the joker harvey
loses the love of his life as well as
his faith in the judicial system it's
this bitter realization that the system
will always be rigged against decent
people that triggers harvey's
transformation into the villainous
two-face harvey's journey gave rise to
one of the most popular quotes in modern
cinema you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain
john connor from the terminator series
is right up there with neo and luke
skywalker as the archetypal chosen one
character as the leader of the
resistance against the evil ai skynet
jon was destined to save humanity in the
future war between man and machines but
then 2015's terminator genesis decided
to take the whole thing in a new
direction it's revealed that during one
of the franchise's patented time
traveling hijinks john connor had been
attacked by the t-5000 terminator as a
result jon is infected with machine
phase matter and turned into a
terminator himself many longtime fans
were mind blown and critical of the
decision to show jon in this new evil
light but the hull arc was still better
received than what the makers decided to
do to john connor in terminator dark
fate
scooby doo's nephew scrappy doo was a
popular character among fans of the
original cartoon which is why it made
sense to include him in the 2002
live-action scooby-doo film
unfortunately fans got more than they
were looking for with the live action
scrappy he believes he has been solely
responsible for the success of the
mystery inc gang and announces himself
as their new leader this prompts the
gang to unceremoniously dump scrappy all
of this leads to the final act of the
movie in which scrappy is revealed to be
the mastermind behind the story's main
crimes to cap it all off scrappy uses
supernatural means to transform into a
hulking demonic entity that tries to
destroy mystery inc in the end scooby
and the gang were able to stop his
power-hungry nephew but the relationship
between scooby and scrappy is unlikely
to ever be repaired
the dark phoenix saga is possibly the
most famous x-men comic storyline of all
time naturally the live-action movies
decided to incorporate the storyline
into their series and that's how movie
audiences got to see righteous hero and
general voice of reason gene grey
transform into the genocidal super
villain phoenix in 2006's x-men the last
stand we see jean return from the dead
after heroically sacrificing her life to
save the other x-men in x2 but this new
version of gene is far removed from the
original which she proves in her first
scene by killing scott the love of her
life matters get even worse when magneto
manages to sway gene over to his side of
the mutants versus humans debate the
movie ends with gene looking to kill
basically everyone around her until a
sobbing wolverine is forced to stab her
to death
years later the franchise made another
attempt to adapt the phoenix storyline
for the big screen in 2019's x-men dark
phoenix
2019's joker proved that even one of the
worst comic book villains ever can win
the sympathy of the audience with a
compelling enough backstory joker
focuses on struggling clown actor arthur
fleck and his attempts to make it as a
stand-up comic arthur is far removed
from the iconic clown prince of crime at
first he is a simple man who likes to
make people laugh wants to help his
ailing mother get better and dreams of
performing stand up in front of cheering
crowds instead of the indifferent
audiences he faces every day as an
unknown comic over time we see arthur's
attitude change as life continuously
beats down on him he gets assaulted made
fun of for his medical condition and
fired from his day job even worse his
stand-up routine is used to make a
mockery of arthur's comic talent by his
favorite big time talk show host when
arthur finally snaps and becomes the
maniacal joker there is little surprise
just a sense of inevitability max
eisenhart's tragic story begins during
world war ii when his entire family is
massacred in concentration camps max is
spared because he's found to be a mutant
and the nazis want to make use of his
power over metal for their own ends when
max manages to escape he takes on the
identity of eric lyncher and dedicates
his life to destroying his former
enemies in the middle of his mission
eric meets charles xavier and the other
x-men they inspire him to step away from
his vengeful path and become a force for
good together eric and charles travel
the world together finding and
recruiting young mutants in need of
guidance and safety but in the end eric
can't ignore his hard-line sensibilities
over time he became convinced that
humans and mutants could never co-exist
and so eric created his own rival
faction of the brotherhood of mutants
dedicated to a new world order where
mutants ruled over mankind
eric's descent into super villainy is
all the more tragic when you think about
how close he came to becoming a genuine
hero alongside charles instead of
turning into the x-men's arch enemy
anakin skywalker was all set to become a
legendary hero destined to bring balance
to the force but that was not to be
anakin's career starts out promisingly
enough he's strong in the force stronger
perhaps than even master yoda anakin
becomes known as the hero with no fear
who could go on the most dangerous
missions alongside his mentor obi-wan
kenobi and always emerge victorious
after falling in love with and secretly
marrying senator padme amidala of naboo
anakin's all set to become a caring
family man but all that changes when
anakin begins to have visions of his
wife dying during childbirth obsessed
with saving her anakin is lured to the
dark side by the sith and takes on the
moniker darth vader in his new identity
anakin turns against his former allies
and is ultimately very nearly killed in
a pitched battle with obi-wan after
being left for dead his broken body is
rebuilt into the classic version of
darth vader that fans know and love
one of the most tragic figures in the
entire marvel cinematic universe is
bucky barnes later to be known as the
dreaded master assassin the winter
soldier bucky's mcu journey starts well
he volunteers to fight in world war ii
alongside his childhood friend steve
rogers unlike steve bucky is accepted on
the first try later after steve is given
the super soldier serum and embarks on a
dangerous mission bucky is right by his
side until he's seemingly taken out by
hydra forces but that's only the start
of bucky's nightmare he pops up decades
later in present times as a winter
soldier a brainwashed assassin who has
received the same serum as steve rogers
with the help of steve bucky is finally
able to break his conditioning but the
many murders he has committed as an
assassin continue to haunt him along
with a question of whether he'll ever be
able to completely absolve himself of
the guilt
played to perfection by al pacino in the
godfather movies michael corleone's
struggle between his decent nature and
his legacy as the son of a mafia boss
drives the main plot of the series when
we first meet michael it is clear that
he has no interest in following in his
father vito's footsteps as the new dawn
of the corleone crime family for his
part not even vito wants michael to
become embroiled in the family business
but that's not what fate has in mind
after an attack is made on vito's life
michael has no choice but to follow in
his father's path he becomes a member of
the corleone crime family showing a
talent for the work that surprises his
friends and enemies alike michael's
civilian life continues to tug at him
but he has no choice but to delve deeper
into a life of crime once he finally
succeeds his father as the new dawn and
thus the cycle of violence continues for
the next generation of corleones
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite heroes turned villains are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one